مساء الخير مع صدور حكم نهائي وبات من
المحكمه الاداريه العليا في مصر بمصريه
جزيرتي تيران وصنافير التي تطالب بما
السعوديه دخلت قضيه الجزيرتين في متاهه
قانونيه
و سياسيه في مصر ومعها دخلت الحكومه
المصريه وعلى راسها الرئيس عبد الف فتاح
السيسي في ازمه سياسيه كبيره طبيعه الازمه
وتبعتها وتاثيرها على الداخل المصري وطبعا
تاثير ده على العلاقات بين مصر والسعوديه
هو موضوع حلقتنا النهارده الحقيقه علشان
نذكر الناس بالازمه بدات ازاي اذكركم بانه
الا ازمه الجزيرتين بدات من طريق الخرقاء
او الخاطئه للحكومه المصريه في التعامل مع
هذا الملف الحكومه المصريه كما علمنا بشكل
مفاجئ يوم 8 ابريل ان هي اعلنت في وسط
حزمه اخرى من الاتفاقات التي وقعتها مع
الجانب
السعودي اثناء
حضور الملك السعودي في القاهره في ابريل
2016 اعلنت مجموعه من الاتفاقات جيده جدا
اتفاقات تعاون واتفاقات استثمار واتفاقات
تجاره وفجاه الحكومه اعلنت ببساطه ان هناك
من بين هذه الاتفاقات اتفاق لترسيم الحدود
البحريه بين مصر
والسعوديه المصريين ماسمعوش اطلاقا عن هذه
الاتفاقيه بشكل مسبق ولم يتم الاعداد ليها
وفجاه عرفنا ان اتفاقيه ترسيم الحدود تعني
من بين ما تعني انتقال ملكيه جزيرتي تيران
وصنافير من مصر الى السعوديه
و منذ ذلك الوقت انقسم المصريون الى
فريقين فريق يصدق الحكومه التي اقسمت
باغلظ الايمان ان لديها وثائق تؤكد ان
الجزيرتين مملوكتين للسعوديه
وانه يعني اداره مصر ليها طوال عشرات
السنوات لا تعني انهما مملكتان لمصر تمام
وفي فريق صدق الحكومه المصريه خصوصا بعد
ما طلع الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي على
شاشات التلفزيون محاطا بكبار رجال
الدوله و وبيجز انه لكل الهيئات وتاكد
تماما من ان الجزيرتين سعوديتين وبما ان
السعوديه دوله شقيقه وهي ليست اسرائيل ومن
غير المتصور ابدا ان مصر ممكن تتنازل عن
جزء من ارضها فهو يرى ان الحل المناسب ان
يعطي ل البلد الشقيق هذه الجزر التي يؤكد
انهما مملوكتين لها وفريق اخر لم يصدق
الحكومه وشكك في روايتها منذ البدايه ولجا
الى المحكمه لجا الى القضى واشتبك الطرفان
في اجراءات تقاضي استمرت عده شهور حوالي
تسع شهور الى الان اجراءات وتفاصيل كثيره
المفاجاه ليست ان المحكمه الاداريه العليا
في
مصر حكمت بشكل نهائي وبات بعد اجراءات
تقاض مختلفه بان الجزيرتين مصريتان لغايه
دلوقتي مش هي دي المفاجاه المفاجاه ان
الحكومه المصريه كما قال الح
فشلت في ان تقدم الى المحكمه ما يثبت
دعواها بان الجزيرتين
سعوديتان القصه دي وضعت علامات استفهام
كثيره ليه
الحكومه فشلت في ان تثبت وجهه نظرها في
وجهه نظر
بتقول مثلا ودي في الغالب هي الروايه اللي
تتبناها الجانب السعودي السعوديه بتقول
احنا قدمنا الجانب المصري الكثير من
الوثائق اللي بيثبت انه الجزر مملوكه
للسعوديه وهو ده الجانب اللي بتتفق عليه
الحكومه المصريه بتوافق المملكه العربيه
السعوديه فلما المحكمه تقول انه لم يصلها
اي ادله تثبت صحه كلام صحه كلام الحكومه
المساله تتعلق بالجانب المصري مش بالجانب
السعودي تثبت ادعاءات الحكومه ان
الجزيرتين سعوديتان يبقى الجانب السعودي
هيقول حعت زي جانب اخر من المصريين ان
الحكومه كانت لديها امتنعت عن تقديم
الوثائق حتى تتملص من وعودها للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولا تقوم بنقل الجزيرتين
تجنبا لغضب لم تتوقعه من فئات الشعب
المختلفه ادي
احتمال في احتمال اخر انه الحكومه قليله
الحيله كانت لديها الوثائق وقدمتها بالفعل
لكن هي فقط المقتنع بان هذه الوثائق كافيه
لاثبات عدم تبعيه الجزر الى مصر ولم تكن
كافيه لاقناع القضاء والخبراء الذي استعان
بهم القضاء ادي روايه اخرى روايه ثالثه
يتبناها عدد اخر من الاطراف المعنيين انه
الحكومه قالت الكلام ده ولم يكن لديها
بالفعل من الوثائق ما يثبت ان الجزر مصريه
ثم حصلت على هذه الجدر نتيجه الزخم الكبير
اللي حصل بعد اثاره القضيه انا شخصيا
تحدثت مع
شخصيه مهمه جدا مهمه
جدا باعتبار ان لديها خبرات كبيره في مجال
ترسيم الحدود
والوثائق وقال لي الاتي قبل ان اتي
حضراتكم لهذه الحلقه قال لي ان الحكومه
بالفعل وقت ان اعلنت
عن ترسيم الحدود عن اتفاقيه ترسيم الحدود
ونقل الجزيرتين الى السعوديه كانت تفتقر
الى هذه الوثائق وانه امد الحكومه المصريه
بكثير من الوثائق التي تثبت ان هذه الجزر
مصريه هذه الشخصيه اللي انا بكلم حضراتكم
عليها سبق ان ساعدت عدد من دول الخليج
والدول الاخرى في اوروبا في حسم نزاعات
الحدوديه طيب ومن وجهه نظر هذا المصدر
اللي طلب ان انا لا اذكر اسمه ان اهميه
الجزيرتين ليس فقط في كونهما يعني في مدخل
خليج العقبه وبالتالي
بيحتلم استراتيجيه مهمه جدا
في الملاحه في البحر الاحمر لكن الاهم
كمان ان هم هيكتسب اهميه اقتصاديه كبيره
جدا جدا لانه وفقا
ليه بين الجزيرتين في ثروات ضخمه من الغاز
ومن النفط سوف تعود على البلد اللي هيحصل
على الجزيرتين بكثير من الفوائد قد يكون
كلام المصدر سليم وقد يكون غير
دقيق كلها سيناريوهات تحتمل الخطا والصواب
والحقيقه هتكشف عنها السنوات القادمه ا
لما نعرف ايه تفاصيل وكواليس هذه
الاتفاقيه سواء من الجانب المصري او من
الجانب السعودي لكن المؤكد جدا ان الحكومه
ايا كان السيناريو الصحيح وضعت نفسها في
مازج كبير جدا ربما هي لا تدرك حتى الان
ابعاده تخيلوا معايا لو ان الحكومه تراجعت
وامتثلت الى امر القضاء المصري ولم تسلم
الجزيرتين هيعود عليها الضرر بحاجتين
الحاجه الاولانيه انها يثبت ان الحكومه
المصريه كانت ترغب في تسليم اراضي مصريه
الى دوله اخرى دون على الاقل لو افترضنا
فيها حسن النيه دون ان دون سندات كافيه او
انها لم تبذل على الاقل من المجهود ما ا
يتيح
لها التاكد من حقيقه ان الجزر مصريه ام
غير مصريه ولو افترضنا سوء النيه وده امر
وارد جدا يعني مش هيكون غريب ان حد يفترضه
ان الحكومه كانت راغبه في التفريط في جزء
من الاراضي المصريه
ا لبلد اخر بغض النظر سعوديه او غير
سعوديه وهذا امر لا شك انه سوف يؤثر ليس
فقط في شعبيه الحكومه اللي هيتم اقالتها
قريبا او تغييرها قريبا ولكن
في شعبيه
و شرعيه نظام الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
نفسه باعتباره انه راعي الاتفاقيه وان لم
يوقع عليها وهذه قصه اخرى لو افترضنا
السيناريو الاخر ان الحكومه اصرت على
تمرير الاتفاقيه التي الغاها القضاء
المصري باي من الطرق سواء بالطعن على يعني
باللجوء للمحكمه الدستوريه عن طريق مجلس
الشعب وهو الامر الاهم انه استطاعت
الحكومه اقناع اعضاء البرلمان والاغلبيه
فيه بتمرير الاتفاقيه في هذه الحاله سوف
يكون الامر اكثر سوءا لانه استقر لد
قطاعات كثيره من المصريين بعد حكم القضاء
ان هذه الجزر مصريه وانه من الغريب جدا ان
الحكومه تقاتل حتى تثبت عكس ذلك الامر ده
هيلقي بضلاله بشكل اكثر على الحكومه وعلى
الرئيس السيسي ويضع في مازق كبير مازق
الحكومه هي اللي بداته زي ما اوضحنا في
الحلقه اللي قلت لحضراتكم عليها بعنوان
اسباب غضب المصريين من عوده تيران و
صنافير الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لانها لم تكن شفافه ولانها
استخفت بالمصريين وافترضت ان هي عارفه
مصلحته وانه ما فيش اي ما يمنع ان احنا
نتفاوض لعده شهور مع السعوديين واحنا محل
ثقه الناس وبالتالي ما فيش اي ما يمنع ان
احنا نخرج على الناس
ونفاجأ هذا كان سوء تقدير ادى الى تحول
المساله او القضيه الى ازمه كبيره سوف
تتتابع اثارها في الفتره القادمه اشكركم
والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله